thomson bonjour merci d'être haut en
direct avec nous ce matin alors on viens
de l'entendre les dernières restrictions
sanitaires sont levés depuis 7 mai au
royaume uni une décision prise alors que
les scientifiques se montre inquiet juge
cette levée dangereuse à paris osé voire
risqué pour à boris johnson est bien ici
bas le risque fait partie de la de la
condition humaine a dans tous les pays
c'est le cas aussi en france aux états
unis en allemagne et ailleurs on se
trouvent confrontés à l'obligation si on
est en position en robe à semer des des
décisions de soupeser le pour et le
contre par rapport à une plus grande
levée des restrictions ou une politique
où tout le monde reste concerné et eux
j'ai vu que vous avez passé un vidéo à
que j'ai pu regarder en préparant cette
émission a de beaux restes en scène et
il explique ensuite cette vidéo que en
fait c'est le bon moment a pour lever
des restrictions parce que on est en été
c'est une période où les conditions
météorologiques sont moins favorables
pour la transmission de virus ou les
écoles et universités sont fermées et le
niveau de vaccination est très élevé au
royaume uni donc ce sont toutes ces
considérations qui ont mené le
gouvernement a décidé la levée des
restrictions il ya des des critiques
d'ailleurs au royaume-uni disons que les
quelques limitations qui reste qu'ils
sont très peu nombreux sont sont encore
de trop car il s'est éteint il ya tout
un débat là-dessus il ya des avis
divergents mais non je pense pas du tout
que ce soit il responsable de cette une
prise de risque
raisonner mesurée et raisonnable
barbara johnson qui lui même est passé à
l' isolement à puisqu'elle est
qu'à contacter alors qu'aujourd'hui
voilà tous les britanniques peuvent
circuler librement sans masque est ce
qu'il ya eu d'une part ou d'autre
certaines aussi pression peut-être
politiques économiques qui ont motivé la
décision de boris johnson
oui toute affaire il y a eu des
pressions de la part d d d hommes loyaux
des milieux d'affaires si vous voulez
pour permettre à la vie économique de
reprendre et et
mais je ne dirais pas qu'il a succombé
lâchement au des pressions des milieux
économiques
encore une fois la prise de décision n'a
pas été précipitée c'est un sujet qui
est sur la table depuis des semaines
voire des mois parce que je rappelle que
le le taux de vaccination au royaume uni
est assez élevé depuis un certain temps
maintenant en pleurs je sais qu'il a des
scientifiques qui estiment que le
gouvernement a va trop loin
bon ça c'est lors leur avis émanant
nacre on a aussi été très critiqués
quand des scientifiques fin mars quand
il a décidé de libéraliser fortement la
situation en france
finalement maintenant tout le monde
s'accorde pour dire que imane y en a
qu'on a eu raison
et j'espère que ce soit la même chose en
ce qui concerne les décisions de poster
ce n'est son gouvernement
ces jours ci
de parler de la vaccination royaume uni
juste pour bien comprendre alors les
restrictions sont levés en angleterre
mais pas dans les autres nations du
royaume uni l'ecosse le pays de galles
et l'irlande du nord ont eux adopté un
calendrier plus prudent oui c'est une
particularité du communiqué au parlement
surprend beaucoup en france qui est un
pays très centralisé en encore plus que
l'eau à munich il ya effectivement une
décentralisation des responsabilités en
matière d'aidé gestion des questions de
santé
et c'est vrai que dans d'autres dont les
autres nations comme on dit au wam unis
allaient casser le long du nord
notamment il est en politique plus
prudent pour chacun les responsables
politiques se fixer puis assume assument
leur choix
7 ça n'a rien de choquant en soi c'est
le sens qu'une situation décentralisée
qu'il puisse y avoir des différences
d'appréciation la campagne vaccinale ont
ça a été un succès 1 puisque londres a
montré l'exemple traite aujourd'hui près
de 7 adultes sur dix sont doublement
vacciner immunisé contre le coc vide 19
la campagne actuellement elle progresse
lentement puisque le pays est à la
traîne quand même concernant la
vaccination des adolescents alors
comment est ce que vous expliquer
justement ce ralentissement
là aussi la situation n'est pas sans
rappeler seul que l'on trouve en france
il y a d'abord de la campagne continue
quant à elle de vaccination continue un
je suppose qu'il ya certains jeunes qui
est moins concerné par ce que pour le
risque de formes graves de la maladie
sont sont très faibles
[Musique]
je voudrais donc je pense que ça peut
jouer un rôle
une chose mérite d'être signalé je crois
là le fait que des jeunes peuvent se
croiser dans des matchs de football
ddd boîte nuit et cetera d'une certaine
manière peut avoir du bon par rapport au
combat générale contre le virus parce
que les jeunes peuvent s'infecter
mutuellement si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
sans ce sens que cela donne lieu à un
accroissement significatif du niveau des
hospices hospitalisation ni des dessins
est donc là la part de la population qui
d'ici la rentrée aura été immunisés soit
pour de vaccination soit du fait d'avoir
été infectées sans que cela donne lieu à
des mêmes des symptômes 7le combinaison
de ces deux est fait peu et seul espoir
de des autorités je crois dans les lieux
à un niveau très élevé de la population
qui est immunisé et et donc il est à
espérer que à la rentrée ce sera un
niveau permettant de parler d'une
immunité collective à 100%
là quand même un niveau très élevé et et
est du coup pour affronter l'hiver les
conditions sera quand même assez assez
optima merci beaucoup en tout cas paul
thompson d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes vice-président
du parti conservateur britannique en
france